oversight committees in the hell when
they found out about this just turn it
hyperventilating and looked at this as
you know an instance potentially of
domestic spying today on reason TV we're
speaking with Shane Harris the author of
the Watchers the rise of America
surveillance state thank you for coming
on chin thanks for having me your book
opens with an explosion which was always
a good decision I think the bombing of
the Marine barracks in beirut in 1983
why is that the place that you start the
story of surveillance in America well
going back and researching sort of the
history of terrorist attacks and often
what was known before the TAC within the
intelligence community I found a lot of
sort of eerie parallels between 9-11 and
Beirut the Beirut is also important for
the first reason is that it was really
the first instance of religious suicidal
Islamic terrorism against an American
target it was a very dramatic explosion
241 Marines were killed the last time
they lost that many men and one day they
were actually storming the beaches at
Iwo Jima so it was really sort of a
watershed moment but going back and
researching what happened before that
event I found that just like 911 there
were very significant clues that were
missed for instance individual warnings
about car bombings in the previous six
months in Beirut the intelligence
community actually had intercepted or
fielded a hundred different warnings
about car bombings in Lebanon and none
of them were really followed up on or
fused there was an investigation of a
previous bombing actually at the US
Embassy that held a lot of clues for
what kind of terrorists were operating
in Lebanon and then there were actually
intercepted phone calls between sources
in Iran and terrorist elements in
Lebanon ordering them to undertake some
kind of attack against the Americans and
none of this intelligence was ever
actually shared with the Marines on the
ground so that they could fortify their
positions so it was just a sort of eerie
kind of theme that was developing of
missing the dots before the attack and
only afterwards realizing the
significance of all these disparate
fragments of intelligence and realizing
that nobody in government had ever
really put them together and this book
is about those people who were trying to
do that and 83 was really sort of the
first instance of anyone making a
concerted effort to connect
stats let's talk about the phrase
connect the dots because every time
something happens immediately afterward
you get the cable news failure to
connect the dots story and as a person
who doesn't really know that much about
this specific sort of technical side of
this it seems like it's easy to
understand how someone wouldn't have
connected those dots but it's also
infuriating that they missed it that you
know so much was at stake and so much
you know time energy money has been
poured into intelligence in order to
miss this important stuff where do you
kind of come down in that divide I mean
should we at this point given the sort
of technology and you know intelligence
capabilities that we have be able to
connect say the dots for the underwear
bomber on christmas day right yeah well
to take into our bombers are really good
instance you know there's a case where
arguably yes we should have been able to
connect fragments of information that we
had there that wasn't an instance where
but we didn't have enough information on
potential threats now granted even if
you'd connected all those various pieces
of intelligence which included warnings
from his father coming into an embassy
saying he gone to Yemen intercepted
phone calls from al Qaeda operatives in
Yemen talking about a Nigerian that
they'd employed in an operation the fact
that the suspected terrorists name was
put into a database on a watch list it's
kind of appalling in a way that more
wasn't done to try and fuse those
different streams of intelligence to say
wait a minute these there seems to be a
pattern here or we're hearing things
about Nigerians and we're getting a guy
coming into the embassy and should we be
following up on that and I was really
sort of shocked to learn that after that
event that there was no automated system
in place for once you put someone's name
in the master watch list of suspected
terrorists of which by the way there are
500 million names which is a whole other
problem of information overload there's
no automated system to check if the name
you're putting in has actually already
been given a US visa so you've got this
database of names of people who we
probably want to think about keeping out
of the country and we don't
automatically check the records that
would tell us if they've been given
permission to enter the country so I
mean I think in a way it's you could
argue that even in hindsight if you all
these pieces were on the puzzle was
there maybe somebody would not have
actually
in the pattern or realize the
significance of it but those pieces were
never even put together on the table and
the reasons for it really come down to
bureaucrat bureaucratic obstacles
agencies not wanting to share their
information not wanting to connect their
different databases because they want to
protect sources and methods and frankly
information in Washington is power and
the more you control the access to your
intelligence the more powerful you are
as an agency then they're just sort of
these basic technological issues of you
know not being able to automatically
check one name in a database against
another and you know those kinds of
things should be the easy fixes and it's
sort of shocking in a way that nine
years after nine eleven those fixes just
haven't been made in some cases right
and in 1983 it's not so surprising right
that yeah you know car bomb and Beirut
wouldn't be cross indexable but in the
age of Google we think everything should
be sort of double searchable in this way
could you talk a little bit about the
rise of kind of easy access to
information by the general public and
how that's impacted the way that the
surveillance state operates you know
it's definitely changing that with
changing in a couple of ways one I think
they've watched this technological kind
of revolution occur and realized that
now information is out there and freely
available in ways that they could only
have imagined maybe a generation ago I
mean I think that if you would if you
could jump in a time machine and go back
to 1983 and say to somebody the
intelligence community you know one day
there will be this grand electronic
database of names and it will show who
everyone is connected to and what their
hobbies are and where they're going
today and where they've been and it's
going to be called the facebook you know
they would have asked you know what when
did the Russians win the war and when
did this kind of system come into place
this is sort of this like took that
would be considered almost totalitarian
and sort of me Orwellian I guess in a
sense but you know so I think they're
looking at this in this revolution
saying wow okay this has happened now
how do we take advantage of it in the
book you do describe one point where the
commingling of confidential and non
confidential information sort of leads
to this I guess you could say almost a
constitutional crisis and and results in
the shutting down of a promising program
can you describe how that happened this
was a program that it was a special
operations command program known as able
danger and it began in early two
thousand and the idea
was that military commanders wanted to
get a sense of what the global network
of al-qaeda looked like and I'll kind of
had that at that point had just attacked
the two embassies in Africa in 98 this
is you know almost year and a half of
for 911 so they're on the radar of
military commanders the intelligence
community but they don't know how vast
the network is and so they employ this
small unit at the army intelligence
command to use this very innovative kind
of data mining where they're going to go
through classified government databases
of cable traffic intelligence reports to
find what they have in al-qaeda but
they're also going to go out in mind
information on the Internet remember
this is 2000 this is pre google the
internet is sort of a novel source of
information and they're going to go out
and crawl the web essentially to see
what information they can find to and
then they bring that into their
databases as well and marry it up with
the government intelligence and create
these sort of elaborate diagrams of al
Qaeda figures and where they are well
the lawyers at the army look at that and
they say wait a second you're drawing in
information from public sources a lot of
which contains references to us persons
to American citizens just because they
happen to be on the same webpage or
mentioned in the same chatroom thread as
the suspected terrorists are al Qaeda
figures you're pulling that in putting
in a government database mixing it with
classified intelligence this is a
violation of privacy regulations and you
know the lawyers and then oversee
oversight committees and they all when
they found out about this just started
hyperventilating and looked at this as
you know an instance potentially of
domestic spying and the orders that they
gave to the people the analysts who were
doing this enabled danger was shut the
program down and destroy everything that
you've discovered today because the
rules say you have to purge the records
of any references to us persons and this
became rather controversial when five
years later was discovered this program
was running and that they actually had
early signs of some kind of al-qaeda
presence in the United States it was
very vague they needed to go deeper on
it to find out whether it was real or
credible but they never had the chance
to look because the lawyers effectively
came in and said that's domestic spying
you're over the line of privacy shut it
down and destroy everything which is
exactly what they did do you think that
was the right call ultimately I think
that they were reading their privacy
regulations and restrictions very
narrowly but we look at that now and we
thank how absurd the idea that the
government can't actually go out and
look at publicly available information
to try and form some kind of hypothesis
about al-qaeda they weren't targeting
people they weren't pulling these names
in and investigating Americans it was
just a byproduct of the search i mean we
know this when we go out today and you
google yourself and final kinds of
references and connections to other
people we sort of understand that you
know there's sort of an innocuous kind
of aspect to this at the same time when
you're talking about pulling that
information into a government database
yes you have to be more skeptical and
the rules have to be tighter but I think
at the time the lawyers were probably
overreacting and given the the nature of
the mission that these guys had and what
they were actually doing with the
information which was not following up
on Americans and trying to profile US
persons or anything like that they were
just sort of trying to get a handle on
the universe of information about
al-qaeda thank you very much Shay
nervous for coming back thanks for
having me I'm Kathryn manga award for
reason TV
you